[Music]  yeah I got the high kicks and we got the  cold beans got the new 58 Packard with  the folk teams yeah we got the bread  lines rockets whoo we got some every  building crumbling copy Muslims also  places so amazing  we'll take your ass dude no one even  tried that to escape that group and we  got the torture maybe you're a muster  [ __ ] so bad you think you're playing  ball at Rutgers yeah we got the banned  books nothing rhymes a Treasury jail for  magazines even if you're David Gregory  got me on surveillance all be brothers  island check revolvers racist someone  tell his stylist in cube  [Music]  [Applause]  there's nothing you can do worldwide  executions and child prostitution Cuba  Cuba Cuba  [Music]